don't let anybody make you believe then
if you all right now you can't get it
don't let nobody make you believe that
you too old don't let nobody make you
believe that way you are it's too hard
for God you took your eyes off him
don't think that God if you call on him
he will help you so are you already
doing so much all right how'd you lose
your voice basically goes all right I
sent you so much
the truth is out there
showing where we are no we are in this
country comes in heaven thank you so
much all right I don't think they should
be forever
yeah how do you need to relax
no I like my memories contingent I don't
think I'm cool all right China America
put in a lot of work for me to be humble
and be the person I am today
so we at one point you were like a
college student and you had your life
together they take my voice are you yeah
it was just do things especially do you
remember the old me you know people with
money people with money yes
do you remember people do things because
it yeah it's do you remember is that
noise that eyes were I made it yes it's
not a word that happen
I made a deuce so I'm not gonna say
people weren't jealous
that's what do you think my boys ain't
rip me yes they're tamanna do you
remember your life before you got all
the drugs and living on the street and
all that yeah I mean I was living my
boyfriend that I can be a better life
you mean by going away I'm sorry this
important meeting help me right now I
might be in forever pain - three minutes
oh it's all right to say on my last date
they were saying something in wait I'm
gonna [ __ ] with me I was lucky
definitely yeah
to stay away Josie so downtown shake not
my city but I'm hurt are you guys are
gonna you know whirling you don't like
me I understand as he I am a dad you you
have kids or any hug that okay good do
you do ever contact with any members of
your family
yeah kind of thing my dad is your dad
he's all even how much how much rock
crack cocaine
are you using me more like it makes me
funny it's fun like not thirsty cuz I
like I want to feel hot hey it's just
like hey it's for like the craving for
in life I'm thirsty
can you do without it but you have to do
it on crack
you can't there's honey are you open to
maybe changing I don't know these are
morning but after what I do it's up to
them so am I
do you understand I'm gonna know do you
think this whole thing time more
trickery I'm putting up more true things
gonna be fishing yeah I'm great
so I'm the [ __ ] what you think me
let's go up turn up
everybody's murdered I'm sorry when I
hate you no give no brothers and sisters
yeah you were talking good I talked to
your cousin hey my taking care your
cousin yeah saw your video
Ariana ariza Yeah right yeah thanks
Tammy
[Applause]
how are you Rosa got me the money
situation
Amanda do you see that you're kind of
getting worse and worse every time you
speak I mean I'm not getting worse than
worse that's this
I'm the lingo this isn't Wayne look
farmers who stop that right now
you saying I got better but my living
situation my money situation our friends
it's a big situation it's all in a way
for you people didn't hot people didn't
people did not die die people did not
die for this that rent but hey what did
I so what it's fun
would you like to get clean would you
like to go to rehab would you like a
break me I'm good I'm ready for the
world my things I'm stuck in straight
this is your weekend that's calling me
back not a normal situation but it's
like drug use it sounds like no friends
but my what
what is your father say to you yes he
yeah you gonna he's a good guy
I didn't want one people might die from
my situation do you work
yeah Wow come hug me I might be for me
or something two or three minutes sorry
miss Amanda what would you like to see
in here life is there anything you'd
like to see here is there anything you
hope to see ya
users why don't ya
maybe not be so deep breath but I'll go
annex unreasoning online that's it
I mean I love ya I don't know the
country but it seems our younger
anything over
so how everything's here that's true
heart out your every need securely so I
need that I need you so my head comes
down
good got away everything
[Music]
because the Bible says I mean we know we
know exactly what Tito began to think
[Music]
see when we when we got a few days clean
God takes us in the rakia sleep place
takes us off the sidewalk off the curb
and put us in a place all of a sudden we
start thinking we don't do yourself yeah
we go to think
[Music]
you